Speaker 1: One of the biggest questions if Elon
Musk does successfully purchase Twitter is whether
he's going to let Donald Trump back on Twitter.
Donald Trump was banned from Twitter permanently
in 2021. Remember, there are some who say that
Trump was banned from Twitter in order to hurt
him in the 2020 election. He wasn't banned
until 2021. So assuming time moves forward,
which I think we sort of think it does. Unless
you want to get into some metaphysical stuff,
that isn't true. But Trump was banned from
Twitter in 2021. Elon Musk was recently asked,
would you let him back on Twitter? And Elon
Musk said that he would. Now, I have some
thoughts about this that some in my audience may
not agree with. I'll get to those in a moment.
Let's first listen to what Elon Musk said.
Speaker 2: Are you planning to let Donald
Trump back on? Well, I.
Speaker 5: I think there's
there's a general question of
should Twitter have permanent bans?
And, you know, I've talked with
Jack Dorsey about this, and
he and I are of the same mind, which is that
permanent bans should be extremely rare and really
reserved for people where they're trying to get
for accounts that are once. And spam scam accounts
where there's just no legitimacy to
the account at all. I do think that
it was not correct to ban Donald
Trump. I think that was a mistake
because it alienated a large part of the
country and did not ultimately result in
not having a voice. He is now going to be on true
social as well, a large part of the sort of the
right in the in the United States. And so I think
this could end up being, frankly, worse than
having, you know, a single forum where everyone
can debate. So I guess the answer is that I, I
would reverse the ban on him, but I don't own
Twitter yet. So this is not like a thing that
will definitely happen because what if I don't own
Twitter? But my opinion and Jack Dorsey, I want to
be clear shares this opinion is that we should not
have permanent perma bans. Now, no, that doesn't.
Speaker 1: Okay. So Elon Musk says he thinks Trump
was wrongly banned now. Donald Trump was rightly
banned. Let's go through this in stages. Okay.
Trump broke Twitter terms of service. Absolutely.
Trump should have been banned. However,
I am very much in the direction of
lifetime bans should be extremely rare and Trump
probably shouldn't have gotten a lifetime ban.
I'm not saying he should be unbanned today. I
would be completely fine with it having been.
Okay. You incite violence. That's a five year
ban or ten or three years, but it doesn't even
really matter the specifics of it. But I generally
don't believe in irreversible decisions. Not that
a Twitter ban is like the death penalty, but I am
against the death penalty because if you make a
mistake, you can't undo it once you've executed
somebody. So permanent bans for bot accounts,
accounts that are fake, pretending to be
someone else, impersonation, automated activity.
Absolutely. No, no question about that. That those
are bans for life. That's just a purging trash,
right? I mean, we do we perma ban all of that
stuff on you know, on all of our platforms when
we see it, when we see that type of thing. When it
comes to violations of terms of service. I still
am okay with some bans for life, but they've
got to be like, I don't even know. You know,
you livestream yourself committing a crime,
murdering someone you want a lifetime ban.
YouTube does that. All these that that that that's
okay. But even as bad as what Trump did was and he
did really bad things I mean, you can argue that
his actions you can argue his actions in total and
Twitter was part of it led to real world violence.
And it's terrible and he should have been banned.
I still lean towards most cases are
a ban for a specific amount of time,
subject to review and revision. And I
would be fine for that review and revision
to determine Trump gets another three years or
whatever. I'm totally, totally fine with that,
but I would lean heavily in the direction
of these are for a sort of specified amount
of time in general. Now when we talk about Trump
specifically, realistically. He may never change
and he might get back on and do the exact same
stuff. In which case you might say, Well, there's
no reason to think he'd do anything differently,
and so we're going to keep him banned. I'm fine
with that. The other problem, there's two
other problems with this anyway, and it's
sort of like a fraught question. One is we know
that terms of service are inconsistently applied.
They're inconsistently applied in different cases
based on how prominent accounts are, and they're
inconsistently applied also just on the basis of
content. That's just a thing. And I'm not saying
that they're inconsistently applied in terms
of a left or right wing bias. That is a debate,
but I'm not even dipping into that
right now. Just terms of service are
inconsistently applied and we experience that
as well. There are on YouTube, for example.
There are. Because our content is seen by more
people than channels with a thousand subscribers.
There are lots of things we get demonetized for
that other really small channels don't get hit
with just because no one's paying attention.
And you can argue that that's right or wrong or
whatever, but we have an inconsistent application
of terms of service. And then the other thing is,
I am right there with you that the idea of
the bands get reviewed, who does the reviewing
and do we trust them to do the reviewing? And
I don't have an answer to that right now. So
I'm speaking in principle. I think for the most
part, we should almost never have bands for life,
extend them, whatever. Almost like a
parole hearing. I'm fine with that.
Do you trust the people you put in
charge to do? It becomes a real question.